هذا وقرر رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هرزي هاليفي تشكيل فريق امني للبدء في
اجراء تحقيقات في اخفاقات احداث السابع من
اكتوبر بجوانبها الامنيه والعسكريه
والاستخبارات ويضم فريق التحقيق عددا من
المسؤولين الامنيين السابقين من بينهم
وزير الامن ورئيس اركان الجيش السابق شول
مفاز الذي سيراس الفريق بالاضافه الى
الرئيس السابق لشعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
زئيفي فرك والقائد السابق لقياده الجيش
الجنوبيه سامي ترجمان وكل وكل منهم سيتولى
التحقيقات في مجاله وقالت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان التحقيقات ستشمل كذلك سير
العمليات العسكريه خلال الحرب على
غزه ينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره
محمد خيري محمد لو بدانا ب
لجنه التحقيق والبدء
بالتحقيق باحداث السابع من
اكتوبر هل هناك حديث عن سبب البدء او
الاعتزاز
ليس بعد في الواقع حسن لا حديث عن اسباب
بدء التحقيق في ما
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انها اخفاقات السابع
من اكتوبر ولكن يعني هناك
اشارات كانت قد سبقت ذلك وهي الذهاب
الاسرائيلي الى غزه ما بعد الحرب الى
المرحله الثالثه الى عقد الكثير من
الاجتماعات سواء في مجلس الحرب او في
الكابينيت المصغر وهو المجلس الوزاري
للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه في في اسرائيل
وكذلك انعقاد اجتماعات مكثف فه ومتكرره
بنا المستويات السياسيه والعسكريه
والامنيه في اسرائيل لبحث الخطوات القادمه
في قطاع غزه وكذلك ينضاف الى كل هذا
التصريحات الامريكيه والضغوطات الامريكيه
على اسرائيل من اج من اجل فعليا البدء
بمرحله اخرى من مراحل الحرب في قطاع غزه
كل هذا يمكن ان يشير اذا اذا ما وضع معا
في صوره واحده الى ان هناك متغير ما سيجري
خلال الايام القادمه فعليا فيما يتعلق في
الحرب الاسرائيليه على القطاع وبناء على
ذلك قد تكون هذه اللجنه هي يعني تم
تشكيلها هذا الفريق الذي يراسه وزير
الدفاع السابق شاؤول مفاز يعني ياتي في
اتساق مع كل ما يجري اسرائيليا ودوليا وقد
يشير ربما الى ان الخطوه باتت قريبه جدا
ولكن هذه اللجنه يعني هذه اللجنه لا تزال
قيد التشكيل وهي بحاجه الى الكثير من
الموافقات حسن نعم هي اجراءات اي بدا يعمل
بها ولم يبدا التحقيق فعليا بطبيعه الحال
لكن اعلن عن بدء هذه الاجراءات ايضا في في
نفس السياق لوحظ ان الحديث اي بدا يرتفع
بشكل مفصل اكثر عن السابق فيما يتعلق
باليوم التالي للحرب ومن الذي سيحكم غزه
بعد بعد هذه الحرب طبعا على لسان
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ايضا في اي سياق
يمكن وضع هذا
الكلام يعني حسن من تحدث بشكل واضح حول
هذا الموضوع هو وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
قبل ان نعرج الى هذه الخطه يجب الاشاره
الى ان هناك خلافات واضحه بين وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي واب جلنت ورئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو هذا الاخير
يعني هو يرفض الحديث عن غزه ما بعد الحرب
حتى الان يعني رغم انه اليوم قد عقد
اجتماع في المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
الامنيه والسياسيه الا ان نتنياهو الذي
حضر هذا المجلس والذي تحدث مع الوزراء ومع
ومعظم هؤلاء الوزراء هم في الحقيقه يعني
من ائتلافه الحكومه الا انه لم يصرح رسميا
هو يعني ربما يمكن القول انه الوحيد من
قيادات مجلس الحرب الذي لم يصرح ولم يتحدث
عن غزه مع بعد الحرب خلال الايام الماضيه
وربما هذا يعني يعزى الى تمسكه بموقفه عدم
بحث هذا الموضوع رغم كل الضغوطات
الامريكيه ورغم الخلافات مع المستوى
العسكري والمستوى الامني في اسرائيل الخطه
التي نشرت اليوم والتي يعني ايضا هي اثارت
جدلا واسعا في اسرائيل وانتقادات كثيره من
قبل عدد من الوزراء ومنهم من هو عضو في
الكابينيت المصغر تتضمن هي مرحله او رؤيه
اوليه وضعها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي تتضمن
يعني تقليل عدد تقليل العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بدايه في شمال قطاع غزه ولكن
اسرائيل تقول انها سوف تستمر في العمل
المكثف في الجنوب وخاصه في مدينه خانيونس
للبحث عن قيادات حركه حماس كما تقول
واعاده الاسرى الاسرائيليين وكذلك يرى
جالنت انه يعني يريد تريد اسرائيل الاتفاق
مع زعماء عشائر وبعض القيادات المحليه في
قطاع غزه من اجل اداره المرحله القادمه
لكن دعنا نقول ان اسرائيل تريد للمرحله
القادمه ان تكون تحت اداره مدنيه في قطاع
غزه ولكنها تريد ان تسمح لجيشها بحريه
العمل داخل اراضي القطاع